[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم ليلى الشيخ
لي في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من يورك وتحديدا
مبنى الامم المتحده حيث عقدت اليوم جلسه
لمجلس الامن الدولي
ركزت على التداعيات الانسانيه لوقف العمل
باتفاق البحر الاسود لتصدير الحبوب
الاوكرانيه
والى السودان
والصوره من الخرطوم مباشره وستصاعد
المعارك في جبهات القتال وتحذيرات امميه
من تداعيات الهجمات على القطاع الصحي
تحديدا
والى واشنطن الان واعلان البيت الابيض انا
السبعه شركات متخصصه بالذكاء الاصطناعي
التزمت بجعل التكنولوجيا التي تصنعها اكثر
امانا باضافه علامات مائيه مثلا على الصور
المفبركه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
ازمه تتصاعد في اسرائيل اكثر من 1200 طيار
وتقني بسلاح الجو يعلنون رفضهم الخدمه
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يصف الخطوه
بالمقلقه ويدعو الى وقف تمرير التشريعات
الخاصه بالتعديلات القضائيه نتنياهو يعتبر
رفض الخدمه العسكريه تهديدا لامن اسرائيل
وقاده المعارضه يتهمون حكومته بقياده
اسرائيل الى حرب الاهليه
[موسيقى]
تصعيد عنوانه البحر الاسود الامم المتحده
تحذر من تبعات كارثيه لخطر اتساع النزاع
تشمل احتمال حدوث مجاعه روسيا تجري
تدريبات عسكريه يتخللها اطلاق صواريخ في
البحر الاسود وردا على قرار روسي مماثل
اوكرانيا تعلن انها ستتعامل مع اي سفينه
متجهه الى الموانئ الروسيه على البحر
الاسود على انها اهداف عسكريه
[موسيقى]
تصعيد ميداني في السودان الاشتباكات تحتدم
في ضواحي الخرطوم ومدينه الاوبيض
الاستراتيجيه ووزير الخارجيه السوداني
يقلل من احتمالات التوصل الى هدنه في مسار
مفاوضات جده اطباء بلا حدود تقول ان فريقا
تابعا لها تعرض لهجوم في العاصمه الامم
المتحده تحصي اكثر من 50 هجوما على قطاع
الرعايه الصحيه
تمديدا بسمح السويد بحرق نسخ المياه
المصحف الشريف والعالم العراقي امام
السفاره العراق في ستوكهولم مظاهرات في
بغداد ومحافظات عراقيه اخرى السويد تعلن
سحب موظفي سفارتها من بغداد لاسباب امنيه
[تصفيق]
وعواصم عربيه واسلاميه تستدعي سفراء
السويد لديها للاحتجاج
وفي لقائنا اليوم قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا المخاطر بعيده المدى على
الامن الغذائي العالمي في ظل الهجمات
الروسيه على موانئ اوكرانيا على البحر
الاسود لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع
كنا طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي برايكم ما
التداعيات المحتمله للتصعيد العسكري في
البحر الاسود في اعقاب وقف العمل باتفاقيه
تصوير الحبوب الاجابات جاءت على النحو
التاريخ
18% رجحوا ارتفاع اسعار الحبوب وحدوث
مجاعه في مناطق ناميه بينما قال
29% ان الامور متجهه نحو تصعيد التوتر بين
روسيا والدول الغربيه اما ثلاثه وخمسون في
المئه فيعتقدون انه سيتم العوده للتفاوض
للتوصل لاتفاق جديد لتصدير الحبوب هذا
سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا الرقميه
يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو
ار الذي يظهر الان على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقيه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
ازمه في التعليم الابتدائي بتونس الاف
المعلمين يتمسكون بمطالب ماليه ويرفضون
التسليم نتائج التلاميذ السنويه ووزاره
التعليم تقيل مئات من مديريه المدارس
وتحجز على الرواتب
[موسيقى]
تحتدم المواجهه بين الحكومه الاسرائيليه
اليمينيه المتطرفه برئاسه نتنياهو
والمعارضه بشان مشروع التعديل القضائي
الذي سيعرض على الكنيست للتصويت يوم
الاثنين المقبل وكان اخر تطور في المشهد
المحتقن في الشارع وداخل اروقه السياسه
والجيش هو التجميد اكثر من الف طيار وفني
نشاطهم التطوعي احتجاجا على تعديل بند
المعقوليه الذي يقلص من صلاحيات المحكمه
العليا لصالح الحكومه ونقلت القناه
الثانيه عشره الاسرائيليه عن وزير الدفاع
قوله انه يجب وقف التعديلات القضائيه
فالوضع مقلق بعد موجه الاستقالات في
الاحتياط
اسرائيل المنقسمه حتى بشان الرسائل هذا
الفيلم الدعائي للجيش اختلفوا قبل ان يسحب
من العرض خطوات الاصلاح القضائي للحكومه
اليمينيه المتطرفه تقابلها خطوات عدد كبير
من المتظاهرين في مسيرات احتجاجيه ضدها
التعديل المقترح لبند المعقوليه في قلب
معركه ساخنه بين رئيس الوزراء بن يمينه
نتنياهو وخصومه يتهمونه بتقويض القضاء
وتقليص صلاحيات المحكمه العليا ومن سخريه
المشهد ان يحتج جنود شاركوا او سيشاركون
في قمع الشعب الفلسطيني ضد قانون يهدد حسب
زعمهم الديمقراطيه في اسرائيل التي تمضي
نحو الديكتاتوريه في حال تحول مشروع
القانون الى قانون نافذ اخر فصول المواجهه
في الحرب الداخليه المفتوحه منذ يناير
الماضي
ابلاغ اكثر من الف ومئه طيار وفني في سلاح
الجو وقف نشاطهم التطوعي بسبب التعديلات
القضائيه المقترحه وكان 161 طيارا وتقنيا
بسلاح الجو اعلن هذا الاسبوع تعليق نشاطهم
التطوعي لنفس السبب
خطاب رئيس الوزراء الخميس مساء لم يغير
شيئا في خطط المتظاهرين الذين ينوون
الاستمرار في احتجاجاتهم سواء خارج
الكنيست او في شوارع القدس وتل ابيب وحيفا
ومدن اخرى لما تسمى الدوله العبريه
يتبادلون نتنياهو ومعارضوه الاتهامات بشان
حاله الفوضى والتشرذم التي تسود البلاد
ومؤسسه الجيش
رفض الخدمه العسكريه هو نهايه الديمقراطيه
ويشكل خطرا على امن كل الاسرائيليين في
النظام الديمقراطي الجيش يخضع للحكومه ولا
يخضع الحكومه عندما تحاول جهات داخل الجيش
وعن طريق التهديد املاء سياسه الحكومه هذا
امر مرفوض انت كذاب هكذا رد عليه يا
ايرلافيد زعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه
هو رئيس حكومه يفكك الدوله ويكذب بدلا من
قول الحقيقه وخلافا للكذب الذي سمعناه منه
اؤكد ان كل قاده المعارضه خرجوا ضد دعوات
رفض الخدمه العسكريه وقلنا ذلك الف مره
ترشق بين الساسسه وبين المتظاهرين وقوات
الامن سيستمر حتى الاثنين المقبل او ربما
بعده فيوم الرابع والعشرين من الشهر
الجاري سيصوت الكنيست على الاصلاحات
وابرزها بند المعقوليه الذي بمقتضاه
استطاع القضاء توجيه تهم الفساد لنتنياهو
هذا البند يسمح للمحكمه العليا ان تمارس
رقابه قضائيه على اذرع السلطه التنفيذيه
اي الحكومه والوزراء والهيئات الرسميه
التابعه لها المعركه الداخليه لم تمنح
حلفاء تل ابيب في الخارج من ابداء رايهم
المعارض للاصلاحات في تعليق سابق للرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن دعقاده اسرائيل الى عدم
التسرع وعبر عن اعتقاده بان افضل نتيجه هي
الاستمرار في السعي الى اوسع توافق ممكن
تتقلص فرص التوافق وتتسع دائره الاحتجاجات
ضد اصلاحات قضائيه قضت ولو نسبيا على وحده
اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
ومعنى الان من تل ابيب العليمه المحلله
العسكري في هيئه الاذاعه الرسميه
الاسرائيليه
وكذلك ينضم
الينا ضيف اخر بعد قليل ولكن ابدا معك سيد
اياد عليمه اذا ما حجم الضرر الذي يمكن ان
يلحق بجهوزيه سلاح الجو وباقي وحدات الجيش
الاسرائيلي في حال فعلا مضت هذه
الاستقالات في الاحتياطات وهذا القلق من
جانب وزير الدفاع
القلق في مواقع هو في صفوف القياده
العسكريه على راس هؤلاء الذين
يعربون عن قلقيما من هذه الظاهره ويبدو ان
الجميع يبدئ جيدا معنى هذا
التحرك بمعنى انه يمس بجاهزيه القتاليه
للجيش بشكل
[موسيقى]
دعينا نشير الى انه يوم امس فقط
الدوائر العسكريه بان الاحتجاجات لن تمس
في هذه المرحله بجاهزيه الجيش بجازيه
القتاليه ولكن مع التاكيد انه في هذه
المرحله اليوم بعد توقيعه وبعد اعلان
حوالي الفا من ضباط الاحتياط عن اثارهم
عدم الاداء الخدمه العسكريه وبضنهم
الطيارين ليس
ضباط يؤدون
الوظائف في التكنولوجيه او صيانه الطائرات
او ما يتعلق بالامور الاداريه وانما هؤلاء
المئات من الطيارين الذين في الواقع يؤدون
النشاط
او ولكن هل هذا هل هذا كافي فعلا ليحرك
نتنياهو باتجاه
ان يقوم بالشيء لمنع هذه الاجراءات
القضائيه خصوصا انه استجاب في مارس الماضي
عندما كان هناك تهديد وجمد بعض الاجراءات
لماذا يبدو الان مستهينا بها بهذه الطريقه
ربما هذا هو السؤال الاكبر صحيح في شهر
مارس الماضي قام بتجميد التعديلات
القضائيه ولكن هذه المره
ونتني الذي قال بنفسه انه لا يهتم ان يتم
اغلاق جناح او اكثر من ذلك في سلاح الجو
وانه مصر على المضيه قدما في هذه
التعديلات في هذه المرحله ليس من الواضح
الى اين يتجه نتنياهو هل فعلا سوف يقوم
بتجميد هذه
التعديلات القضائيه ربما نشير الى ان وزير
الدفاع وعلى خلفيه ما نشرى مساء اليوم في
شبكات التلفاز المختلفه الاسرائيليه اصدر
بيانا اوضح فيه بانه لما يحضر ولم يعلن عن
قراره التراجع او عدم ما دعمه
للتعديلات القضائيه وانما فقط سوف يسعى
الى الوصول الى تفاهم بين كل الجهات وهذا
بلسان اخر يعني انه لا ينوي القيامه
بخطوه على غرار ما فعلها قبل بضعه اشهر في
شهر مارس والذي ادت في نهايه الامر الى
اقالته وقد اعيد بعد ذلك لذلك هناك علامات
استفهام كيف سوف الى اين يتجه رئيس
الوزراء وفي الواقع هذه الاصوات التي تعرب
فعلا عن قلقها هل رئيس الوزراء معني او
مستعد
لتقديم هذه التضحيه ربما ان يعرض
الى اي احد هو مستعد ان يذهب في هذه
المواجهه اشكرك
العليمه مثل ابيب المحلل العسكري في ايات
الاذاعه الرسميه الاسرائيليه وارحب الان
من حيفا خوري الكاتب المختص في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه وابدا من حيث انتهى العليمه
قبل قليل يعني يسال الى اي حد فعلا تسير
الامور خصوصا قبل قليل استمعنا في الكنيست
لمن
يستخدم عبارات حاده جدا مثل كذاب وما الى
ذلك وايضا رئيس الشباك السابق يقول انه
يبدو ان نتنياهو ملتزم اكثر تجاه ائتلافه
الحكومي منه تجاه دوله اسرائيل هذا كلام
كبير الى اي درجه هو شائع وخطير ربما على
هذه الحكومه
مساء الخير لك وللمشاهدين اعتقد يعني اذا
ذهبنا الى صلب الموضوع يجب اولا ان نعمل
على امرين اساسيين ازاله كل ما يرتبط
بالتصريحات الشعبويه من كلا الطرفين وكل
ما يرتبط بالسياسه للانتخابي وكل طرفي
يريد ان يتحدث الى قاعدته
الانتخابيه حتى لو لم يكن هنالك انتخابات
في الافق ولكن واضح ان كل خطاب من كل طرف
وكل كلمه ووجه بالاساس الى الجمهور
الاسرائيلي اذا كان مؤيد الى هذا الطرف او
ذاك وبالتالي نبقى مع جوهر الموضوع جوهر
الموضوع مرتبط بقضيه اساسيه اسرائيل الان
ليست في مسار حرب مع اي طرف خاصه عندما
نتحدث عن سلاح الجو منظومات الكامله اذا
كان في الجيش النظامي واذا كان في جيش
الاحتياط لا يوجد هنالك حرب مع اي دوله في
الجوار انت لست بحاجه الى اسطول جوي جاهز
الان بشكل مباشر بامر عسكري لينفذ عمليات
في العمق اذا كان في دول متاخمه لاسرائيل
او حتى لايران مثلا
انه يعيش حاله التوتر
حتى اوضح الفكره
المشكله الان ليست بالبعد العمليات
العسكري الفوري واضح انه هذا الامر يقلق
الشاشه ويقلق ايضا قاده الجيش وقاده هيئه
الاركان في اسرائيل القضيه الان هي الوضع
الاجتماعي الداخلي في المؤسسه الامنيه
العسكريه وطالما حاولوا ابعاد هذه المؤسسه
عن اي خلاف سياسي رغم التغييرات الجوهريه
التي حدثت في المؤسسه العسكريه من ناحيه
من يتواجد الان في القيادات من يتواجد
الان في المحاور المتخذه للقرار داخل
المؤسسه العسكريه لطالما تعاملت اسرائيل
وعلى مدار السنوات طويله ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي بمنظومته المتكامله اذا كان في
البر او في البحر او في الجو هي فرن الصهر
لاي خلاف داخلي داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي
وبين الشرائح هذا المجتمع اذا كان شرقي او
غربي ابيض ام اسمر وبالتالي عندما تطفلان
على سطح هذه الخلافات وتصل الى من خلال
الطيارين والتقنيين في سلاح الجو وهو يعني
ذروه وقوه الجيش بمفهومه التقني
والتكنولوجي وغير ذلك ودائما يتعاملون مع
الطيارين بانهم فوق الجميع في المؤسسه
العسكريه واضحا ان هذا سيتغلغل الى وحدات
اخرى في الجيش وبالتالي هذا التماسك
الاجتماعي الذي طالما تحدث عنه
العسكريه كبير هذا غير مسبوخ وفي داخل
الاوساط الجيش الاسرائيلي بهذه الطريقه
ولكن السؤال هو كيف سيستجيب نتنياهو هل
يمكن ان يلجا للعنف مثلا وهناك حديث كبير
عن انقسام يعني
واحتدام ومواجهه هل هذا ممكن
هذا ممكن نحن امام ساعات يعني واضح داخل
المجتمع الاسرائيلي انها ساعات يعني حاسمه
ولنذهب الى ما يعرف الان بكسر عظم بين
الطرفين وقد يكون تصريح وزير الامن هذه
الليله يعرف الذي دعا الى التجميد التشريع
والا يذهب الى طرح هذا المشروع المتعلق
بفقره المعقوليه على جدول اعمال الكنيست
للقراءتين الثانيه والثالثه بمعنى اقرار
هذا المشروع يوم الاحد ويوم الاثنين
وبالتالي نحن امام نهايه اسبوع طويله
ستترجم ايضا الى المزيد من الفعاليات
الاحتجاجيه خاصه غدا مساء مع انتهاء عطله
يوم السبت وصولا ايضا الى يوم الاحد او قد
يكون ايضا يوم الاثنين بالمزيد من
المظاهرات والاحتجاجات الشعبيه وشل الحركه
واضح ان هنالك من سيضغط باتجاه فض هذه
الاحتجاجات ولكن هذا قد يؤدي فعلا الى عنف
الى صدام دموي بين
في الميدان لو في الشارع خاصه وان هنالك
دعوات لليمين بان يخرج الى مليونيه في
مطلع الاسبوع
الكاتب المختص في الشؤون الاسرائيليه من
حيفا
[موسيقى]
نفذ سلاح البحريه الروسيه اليوم منورات
صاروخيه على اهداف في البحر الاسود في
المقابل اتهمت اوكرانيا الاسطوله الروسيه
بالتصعيد في البحر الاسود مع استمرار قصف
ميناء اوديسل استراتيجيه وبينما وصف
الكريم
بشان اعتبارها السفن المتجهه الى روسيا
عبر البحر الاسود ذات الصبغه عسكريه بحث
الرئيس الاوكراني مع قاده الجيش والبحريه
تحضير مجموعه من التدابير لمواصله عمل ممر
الحبوب
قباله السواحل الاوكرانيه تستعرض موسكو
قدراتها العسكريه تدريبات بالذخيره الحيه
على سيناريو اعتراض سفن في عرض البحر
والمناورات الميدانيه ليست سوى انعكاس
لارتفاع نبره التهديدات المتبادله بين
موسكو
فمن بوابه اتفاق الحبوب الذي انهار
بانسحاب روسيا منه يعود البحر الاسود الى
دائره الاهتمام منذرا بتصعيد محتمل
اوكرانيا تحذر من انها ستواصل اعتبار جميع
السفن المتجهه الى الموانئ الروسيه اهدافا
عسكريه في رد على تحذير روسي مماثل لترد
موسكو مره اخرى باتهام كياف بالضلوع في
هجمات ارهابيه تهدد الملاحه في البحر
الاسود في اشاره لاستهداف ميناء سيفاستوبل
مقر اسطول البحر الاسود الروسي وموا في
شبه جزيره القرم بما فيها جسر
القرمستراتيجي وهي مناطق تحت السيطره
الروسيه هجمات رد عليها الجيش الروسي حسب
ما اعلنت وزاره الدفاع بقصف مكثف ومستمر
لمدن ساحليه اوكرانيه اهمها
اوديسايف هجمات ذهب مسؤولون روس اثرها الى
حد المطالبه بضم مزيد من المناطق
الاوكرانيه لروسيا لحرمان كييف من اي منفذ
على البحر الاسود
ولمنافذ البحر الاسود اهميه للطرفين كيف
تؤكد انها ستستعيد السيطره على المناطق
التي اقتطعتها روسيا كليا او جزئيا بينما
تتمسك موسكو بالابقاء عليها منفذا للمياه
الدافئه
[موسيقى]
ومعنا الان من اوديسا نتاليا المتحدثه
باسم قياده عمليات الجنوب في الجيش
الاوكراني اهلا بك السيده هوني واريد ان
اسالك عن الوضع في اوديسا حاليا كيف يمكن
وصفه وتاثير الضربات الروسيه حتى الان
عدو طوال ثلاثه ليالي كان يقصف البنيه
التحتيه للموانئ كل ميناء قد
انضم لاعمال نقل الحبوب قد تعرض للضرر
وتدمرت البنيه التحتيه في تلك
الموانئ وحاولوا ان يدمروا كل ما يمكن ان
يساعد اوكرانيا في
الاستمرار باتفاقيه الحبوب للاسف هذه
الهجمات كانت قد ادى لسقوط ضحايا في
اوديسا وضواحيها ايضا هاجم العدو نيكلايف
بصواريخ من نوع اسكندر
ودمر منازل المتعدده الطوابق حيث كان حيث
سقطت ارواح من المدنيين وجرح البعض خمس
اطفال جرحوا الدوله الارهابيه روسيا
حتى تنشر الرعب في اوكرانيا تستخدم وسائل
مختلفه وصواريخ مختلفه في نفس الوقت
تستخدم ما يزيد عن عشرين صاروخ ومسيره ضد
القطاع الجنوبي اليوم في الليل من جديد
قصفوا الجنوب ولكن ليس الموانئ بل المناطق
حيث يقوم
الفلاحين بجمع
المحصود
وجرح وعفوا حرقت بعض
المستودعات ودمرت المعدات وجرح البعض من
المزارعين نعم هذا القصف المتصاعد من جانب
روسيا والاهداف التي تستهدفها هل الهدف
فعلا هو منع تصدير الحبوب ام هناك هدف
عسكري اوسع برايك
لا تبحث هنا عن اهداف عسكريه كل ما يريدوه
هو ان يقوم المجتمع الدولي
باخفاض العقوبات وتقليل العقوبات والضم
البنك الروسي لنظام السويفت واعلنوا انهم
يريدوا ان يتاجروا بحبوبهم وان يبيعوا
حبوبهم للدول الذين يختاروهم ولكن الحبوب
اصلا اوكرانيا شكرا جزيلا لك نتاليا
المتحدثه باسم قياده عمليات الجنوب في
الجيش الاوكراني
وننتقل الان الى موسكو وضيفنا من هناك
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي والعقيده
الاحتياط في الجيش الروسي سيد لتوفكن
كيف تنظرون الى هذا التصعيد الاخير في
البحر الاسود والهدف منه
الهدف واضح وبسيط هو ان نجعل اوكرانيا
تفقد
الابواب والممرات للبحر الاسود لانها
ممرات تساعد اوكرانيا بالقيام بعمليات
ارهابيه على القرم وجسر القرم اوكرانيا
باعمالها وهجماتها الارهابيه على جسر
القرم دفعت الثمن وكان هذا الثمن هو
اتفاقيه
الحبوب وايضا خسروا مصانع للمسيرات
المائيه في اوديسا ونيكالايف والكثير من
المصانع والورش التي تستخدم لتصنيع ادوات
عسكريه بعد ضربه جسر القرم اوكرانيا الان
تفقد البحر الاسود قد لا يكون بشكل كامل
اليوم ولكن غدا سوف تخسره بالكامل
بعد ان تستطيع روسيا ان تحرر اوديس
هل هي اوكرانيا وحدها من سيخسر هنا يعني
العالم كله سيتضرر وخصوصا الدول الناميه
من عدم تجديد هذه الاتفاقيه والاستهداف
منشات الحبوب كما يصر الجانب الاوكراني
على القول
وذكر ان هناك فعلا مستودعات تم تدميرها
بالكامل
ان العالم يتضرر هذه
الزائفه ان الحبوب التي كانت تصدر من
اوكرانيا كانت بنسبه 95% توجه لاوروبا اما
في افريقيا كان هناك ثلاثه بالمئه فقط من
كميه الحبوب تتوجه لهناك لدى روسيا كميه
ضخمه من الحبوب لا يسمح لها بالذهاب للدول
الفقيره لانهم يمنع
السفن ان تحصل على التامين ولا يسمح للبنك
الزراعي ان ينضم النظام البنكي الدولي
وايضا يمنع
السفن الاجنبيه ان تصل لموانئ مناطق روسيا
الجديده حتى تحمل الحبوب الى مناطق مختلفه
من وجه المعموره لذلك هذه مشكله مزيفه
قاموا بافتعالها لان اتفاقيه الحبوب يجب
ان تكون
لطرفين الطرف الاول روسيا والطرف
الاوكراني كانوا يلتزمون مع اوكرانيا
بتصدير الحبوب ولكنهم ينقضون الاتفاقات مع
روسيا وهذا شيء غير مسموح به اشكرك فيكتور
الخبير العسكري والعقيد الاحتياط في الجيش
الروسي من موسكو شكرا
بحث مجلس الامن الدولي تداعيات انسحاب
روسيا من اتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب وقد حذرت
اطراف خلال الجلسه من خطر حدوث نزاع نتيجه
لحادث عسكري في البحر الاسود ومع تاكيد
المندوب الروسيه استعداد بلاده للعوده
المشروطه الى الاتفاق طلب الجانب
الاوكراني المجتمع الدولي باتخاذ اجراءات
لضمان سلامه الملاحه في البحر الاسود
اتفاق نقل الحبوب على طاوله مجلس الامن
تحولت الجلسه التي خصصها المحفل الدولي
لمناقشه تداعيات الانسحاب الروسي من
الاتفاق الى ساحه للتحذير والقاء
الاتهامات وطرح مبادرات ايضا موقف الامم
المتحده بقي على حاله بسعيها لاعاده تفعيل
الاتفاق لكن وكيله الامين العام للشؤون
السياسيه حذرت من احتمال حدوث مواجهه
عسكريه ناجمه عن حادث عسكري في البحر
الاسود
نحث بشده على ضبط النفس تجاه اي خطاب او
عمل اخر من شانه ان يؤدي الى تدهور الوضع
الخطير بالفعل اما وكيل الامين العام
للشؤون الانسانيه فاشار الى ارتفاع اسعار
الحبوب وعوده شبح الجوع الى ملايين الناس
خلاصه القول ان صادره الاغذيه والاسمده من
اوكرانيا وروسيا لا تزال تكتسي اهميه قصوى
لضمان الامن الغذائي العالمي
وكذلك ان لم يتغير الموقف الروسي المستعد
لاستئناف الاتفاق بعد رفع العقوبات على
المنتجات الزراعيه الروسيه رغم تقييمه
بتحول طبيعه الاتفاق من انسانيه الى
تجاريه لكون زوج
لا ينبغي لاحد ان يفاجئ بالقرار الذي
اتخذناه بتعليق مبادره البحر الاسود
وانتهاء الممر الانساني البحري الان جميع
السفن المتوجهه الى مياه البحر الاسود
والموانئ الاوكرانيه ستعتبر من قبلنا
ناقلات لشحنات عسكريه على الطرف المقابل
اتهم المندوب الاوكراني روسيا بالسعي
لترهيب الدول وخلو اعلانها من اي هدف
عسكري مشروع او استثناءات طبيه وانسانيه
وفق قوانين الحرب البحريه دعا المسؤول
الاوكراني من منبر مجلس الامن العالم الى
اتخاذ اجراءات تضمن سلامه الملاحه في
البحر الاسود كضمان للامن الغذائي في كل
العالم
لا يمكن تبرير عمل روسيا باي من قواعد
القانون الدولي بما في ذلك حق المتحاربين
في الحصار اما الولايات المتحده عبر
مندوبتها اشارت الى ان روسيا تصدر حبوبها
اكثر من اي وقت وبسعر اعلى وان الوقت لم
ينفد بعد كي تتراجع موسكو عن موقفها
الحالي وتعيد تفعيل الاتفاق
الليله الماضيه لوحدها شنت روسيا جوله
جديده من الهجمات على اودستا روسيا تشل
حربا على امدادات الغذاء في العالم
كما لم يغب تحضير اطراف حاضره للاجتماع من
تحول البحر الاسود الى منطقه خطيره لا
يؤمن فيها ابحار السفن المدنيه
[موسيقى]
افاد مراسل الجزيره بسماع دوي انفجارات
قويه في ضاحيه الرياض شرقيه الخرطوم وان
الطائرات الحربيه التابعه للجيش ظلت تحلق
بكثافه في سماء مدن العاصمه الثلاث وانا
مضادات الدعم السريع ردت على قصف الجيش
لمواقعها في جنوب وشرق الخرطوم وام درمان
في الوقت نفسه شهدت مدينه الاوبيض عاصمه
ولايه شمال كردفان غربيه السودان شهدت
اشتباكات عنيفه بالاسلحه الثقيله
وتتمتع لبيض بموقع استراتيجيا وتعتبر ملقى
ملتقى طرق الشمال والجنوب والوسط والغرب
والشرق كما يمر عبرها خط انابيب النفط
الممتد من الجنوب الى ميناء بورتسودان على
البحر الاحمر
يتجدد مشهد القصف المتبادل بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع يوميا بصور
مختلفه حسب مراسل الجزيره دوه الانفجارات
العنيفه في حي الرياض شرقي الخرطوم جراء
غاره جويه نفذها الجيش على مواقع الدعم
السريع كما واصل مناطق جنوب ام درمان وذلك
ضمن ما يصفها الجيش بحمله اخراج الدعم
السريع من مختلف مواقع ارتكازاته لكن هذه
القوات تقول انها تحافظ على مواقع
ارتكازاتها وترد على هجمات الجيش الارضيه
واليويه
تجدد القتال وتصاعده يكرس القلق لدى
المنظمات الاقليميه والدوليه العامله في
السودان وتحذر العديد منها من التاثير
السالب المتصاعد على حياه المدنيين
بعثه منظمه اطباء بلا حدود العامله في
الخرطوم والتي يتعامل الطاقمها مع مختلف
اصابات الحرب بما فيها الجراحات المعقده
قالت ان فريقها تعرض للاعتداء من قبل
مجموعه مسلحه وذلك خلال نقل امدادات طبيه
من مستودعات المنظمه وان هذه ليست المره
الاولى التي يحدث فيها ذلك وان استمرار
الاعتداءات المتكرره على طواقمها قد يحول
دون استمرار وجودها في احد المستشفيين
العاملين بجنوب الخرطوم رغم ان هذا
المستشفى يزود المنطقه وما حولها بالادويه
المنقذه للحياه والكوادر المتخصصه
بامكانيه انتهاء النزاع او حتى بوقف دائم
لاطلاق النار
اكد برنامج الغذاء العالميه التابع للامم
المتحده مقتل احد موظفيه برصاص مسلحين
مجهولين في مدينه التربه بمحافظه تعز جنوب
غربي اليمن واضاف في بيان ان الموظف وهو
مواطن اردني توفي بعد وقت قصير من نقله
للمستشفى وكانت وكاله الانباء اليمنيه
الحكوميه افادت رئيس مجلس القياده الرئاسي
رشاد
العليمي وجه بملاحقه العناصر الاجراميه
المتورطه بتنفيذ الاعتداء المسلح الذي
اسفر عن مقتل موظف اممي وجرح اخرين في
مدينه تربه
[موسيقى]
في العراق نظم انصاره التيار الصدري
بزعامه مقتدى الصدر وقفاه احتجاجيه تمديدا
بالاساءه لنسخه من المصحف الشريف التي تم
احراقها وكذلك العلم العراقي امام سفاره
العراق في العاصمه السويديه ورفع المحتجون
الاعلام العراقيه وصور زعيم التيار الصدري
ورددوا هتافات مندده بالحادثه التي اقدم
عليها لاجئ عراقي في السويد وبدات
المظاهرات عقب صلاه الجمعه في مدينه الصدر
شرقيه بغداد وفي عدد من مدن وسط البلاد
وجنوبها وقد اعلنت السويد نقل الموظفين
والعمليات في السفاره السويديه في بغداد
مؤقتا الى استقل لاسباب امنيه
وفي ردود الفعل الدوليه استدعت الخارجيه
السعوديه القائمه باعمال سفاره السويد
وسلمته مذكره احتجاج على منح السلطات
السويديه تصاريح رسميه لمتطرفين اقدم على
حرق وتدنيس نسخ من المصحف وقد طلبت
الرياضه السويد باتخاذ الاجراءات الفوريه
واللازمه لوقف هذه الاعمال التي وصفتها
بالشائنه كما دانت دوله قطر الاعتداء على
المصحف الشريف واستنكرت تكرار السماح بهذه
الافعال في السويد
اما الخارجيه القطريه فقالت انها استدعت
سفيره السويد في الدوحه وسلمته مذكره
احتجاج تطالب ستوكهولم باتخاذ اجراءات
لوقف الممارسات الشائنه
وفي الامارات افادت وكاله الانباء الرسميه
باستدعاء القائمه بالاعمال في سفاره
السويد وابلاغها استنكار الامارات الشديد
لمواصله حكومه السويدا السماح بالاعتداءات
المتكرره على نسخ من القران الكريم
اما المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الايرانيه ناصر
كنعاني فاعلن انه جرى استدعاء السفير
السويدي للاحتجاج على الاساءه للقران
الكريم واضاف الكعاني ان السويد تتحمل
مسؤوليه تداعيات استفزاز مشاعر المسلمين
في جميع انحاء العالم
كذلك دان بيان للخارجيه المصريه بشده
تكرار حالات تمزيق وحرق المصحف الشريف في
السويد واعتبره تحديا سافرا يتجاوز حدود
حريه التعبير ويستفز مشاعر ملايين
المسلمين حول العالم وينتهك مقدساتهم
وقال الازهر ان السويد اثبتت بممارساتها
انها اقرب المجتمعات الى العنصريه وابعدها
عن احترام الاديان والشعوب وحث في تغريده
جميع الشعوب العربيه والاسلاميه على
الاستمرار في مقاطعه المنتجات السويديه
داعيا كل احرار العالم للانضمام الى ذلك
ومؤكدا ان اي تخاذل في اتخاذ مواقف صارمه
تجاه السويد يعد دعما لهذه الجرائم
وتشجيعا لهؤلاء المجرمين
وفق تعبير الازهر
قالت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه ان شابا
فلسطينيا استشهد متاثرا بجراح اصيب بها
برصاص الاحتلال في قريه ام صفا شمال رام
الله وكانت الوزاره قالت في وقت سابق
فلسطينيين اصيبا خلال قمع قوات الاحتلال
مسيره سلميه خرجت في القريه اليوم عقب
صلاه الجمعه تمديدا بالاستيطان ومصادره
الاراضي وقامت قوه الاحتلال باغلاق مداخل
القريه ومنعت السكان من الدخول او الخروج
اليها ومنها كما قمعت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي مصلين فلسطينيين خلال ادائهم
صلاه الجمعه في خيمه الاعتصام المندده
بالاستيطان في بلده سلوان جنوب المسجد
الاقصى واطلقت قوات الاحتلال قنابل الصوت
والغاز الموسيلي للدموع تجاه المصلين
لتفريقهم وفضل الاعتصام وفي بلده بيت ام
مر في الخليل اندلعت مواجهات بين قوات
الاحتلال ومواطنين فلسطينيين مشاركين في
جنازه احد سكان البلده وقالت وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه ان الجنديا اصيب بجروح نتيجه
القاء عبوه محليه الصنع تجاه القوه
العسكريه
والان الى خبر من تونس بعد اعلان نتائج
امتحان الثانويه العامه للعام 2023 عفوا
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه حصل الطالب الشهيد
مجدي عرعراوي من جنين على معدل 90
واربعه اعشار في المئه وكان عرعراوي
استشهد خلال عمليه اقتحام الاحتلال
الاخيره لمدينه جنين ومخيمها كما انها
خمسه من زملاء الشهيد مجدي كانوا يستعدون
لدخول الامتحان لكنهم استشهدوا كذلك برصاص
الاحتلال
كان ذلك في الثالث من يوليو تموز في مخيم
جنين
لم يكن يعرف الاصدقاء الثلاثه الذين
حاولوا حمايه بعضهم ان يقوم قناص اسرائيلي
بقتل احدهم ولكن في فلسطين يمكن ان يحصل
الفلسطيني على شهادتين ان يصبح شهيدا
ويحصل على شهاده التفوق في الثانويه
العامه
اليوم اللي كنا نستنى بايه ام شهيد مجدي
عرعراوي
ذهبت الى قبره لتخبره بالعلامه التي حصل
عليها
زين يا روحي
تشاطر ام مجدي مشاعر غضب وحزن وفرح مع خمس
عائلات استشهد ابنائها قبل ان يعرفوا
نتيجتهم بتفوق في الثانويه العامه
كما القهر يسكن القلوب عشرات الطلبه في
الثانويه العامه الذين اعتقدهم الاحتلال
او اخدعهم للحبس المنزلي
ورغم الاسرى هناك فسحه فرح للعائلات عبد
الله حصل على
96% في الثانويه العامه اعتقل والده وهو
جنين في رحم امه امينه المعلمه اما والده
فمحكوم بالسجن مدى الحياه سبعه عشره مره
كانت فرحتنا منقوصه لان محمد مش موجود
يشاركنا هذا اللحظات اللي هو طبعا اللي هي
هاي لحظات الفرح اللي بتشاركها الاهل
والاحبه مع بعضهم البعض ولكن رغم ذلك احنا
اصرينا اننا نفرح وكانت الفرحه نابعه من
داخلنا لان العلم هو سلاحنا للمقاومه طبعا
يعني العلم سلاح وانا استغليت عشان ابسط
امي وابوي
وقبل فتره رحت على الزياره مع ابوي وحكينا
يعني لقدام عن المستقبل وانه شو بدي ادرس
وان شاء الله يعني واكمل في الجامعه وان
شاء الله يبقى معنا
ورغم القهر ادخلت نتائج الثانويه العامه
الفرحه في قلوب امهات الشهداء
وعائلات الاسرى
في فلسطين كل شيء استثنائي مشاعر الفرح
والحزن تختلط كل يوم اسرى وشهداء قمع
واشتياحات لكن الفلسطينيين يقولون
للاحتلال كل يوم لن ننكسر وسيبقى العلم
سلاحنا الاول
الجزيره من قريه بيت لقيا غرب رام الله
والان الى تونس جددت نقابه التعليم
الابتدائي تمسكها بقرار رفض تسليم دفاتر
نتائج الطلاب السنويه قبل زياده رواتب
المدرسين وتسويه اوضاع من يعلمون منهم
بعقود وصفتها بالمجحفه وقد اعفت وزاره
التعليم المئات من مديرين مدارس وامتنعت
عن صرف رواتب الاف المعلمين وذلك بسبب
انخراطهم فيما تصفها بخطوات تصعيديه في
هذه القضيه وقد تباينت ردود الفعل تجاهها
هذا الخلاف بين الطرفين الامر الذي يؤثر
على الطلاب وعلى اولياء امورهم كذلك
سنه دراسيه مع وقف التنفيذ في تونس
اذ يرفض الاف المدرسين في المرحله
الابتدائيه تسليم دفاتر نتائج التلاميذ
السنويه فهم يطالبون بزياده في اجورهم
فانا وزوجتي
المدام كيف كيف
[موسيقى]
وزاره التربيه
كمعرف وحيد مش كذبات بشريه واقفه في قسم
وزاره التربيه والتعليم لجات الى وقف صرف
المرتبات
واقاله مئات مديري المدارس
ورغم تعبيرها المتكرر عن تفهمها لمطالب
المدرسين وعملها على تسويه بعض المطالب
تؤكد الوزاره ان الصعوبات الماليه التي
تعانيها البلاد تحول دون تنفيذ اتفاقات
سابقه ليس لنا هدف فيما قمنا به الواجب
لان لا يمكن بالفعل ان نقوم ابناءنا
وفلتات اكبابنا اللي الثوم ما يعرفوش
الواحد ناجحين ولا لا حاله الانسداد
والتصعيد المتبادل بين النقابيين ووزاره
التربيه جاءت نتيجه حتميه في ظل تشبت كل
طرف بموقفه من القضايا المطروحه ثم حتى
دوله في العالم تلجا الى
عقاب على نفس الاشكال مرتين عقاب بسحب
الخطه الوظيفيه
وحجب حجب المرتب
حجم المرتب انت اقلتني علاش تحجبلي في
المرتب نتاعي مانيش فاهم وقتاش باش يرجع
مرتبي ولا ما يرجعش الله اعلم اولياء
التلاميذ ينتظرون انفراج الازمه بين
النقابات والوزاره للقضاء
راهو هو خط احمر
ولو حتى القضاء ما انصافش اذا كان الاجراء
غلط
رغم اقتراب موعد الموسم الدراسي الجديد
فان حاله الترقب والانتظار هي الغالبه على
مئات الالاف من العائلات التونسيه
لمعرفه اوضاع ابنائهم الدراسيه
اطراف عديده تدعو الى انهاء الازمه بين
نقابات التعليم ووزاره التربيه
وتقديم التنازلات الضروريه لتحقيق مصلحه
التلاميذ واولياء امورهم ومطالب المعلمين
استعدادا لموسم دراسي جديد سيف الجزيره
تونس
[موسيقى]
سجال سياسي حاد هجمات متبادله حرب جيوسيه
مناورات عسكريه وازمه غذاء هذه هي
العناوين يتصدرها البحر الاسود الذي يسوده
توتر متزايد بين روسيا من جهه واوكرانيا
وحلفائها من جهه اخرى وذلك منذ انتهاء
العمل باتفاق تصدير الحبوب
الاساسي لامدادات الاغذيه في العالم البحر
الاسود هو بحر داخلي بين الجزء الجنوبي
الشرقي من اوروبا
واسيا الصغرى ويتصل بالبحر الابيض المتوسط
عن طريق مضيق البوسفور وبحري مرمره
تصب فيه انهار كثيره يطلق عليه البحر
الاسود ليس بسبب سواد لون مياهه بل لكثره
الغيوم فوقه يعتبر احد ابرز المنافذ
البحريه الروسيه نحو المياه الدافئه وتحيط
به دول روسيا واوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
ورومانيا بلغاريا
وتركيا وجورجيا كما تشاهدون البحر الاسود
نادرا ما يعد من بين اهم المساحات
الاستراتيجيه في العالم حتى بين المسطحات
المائيه لقد حظي بحر جنوب الصين والخليج
العربي وشرق البحر الابيض المتوسط بالمزيد
من الاهتمام في السنوات الاخيره
طبعا هذا على الرغم من وقوع عشر حروب
مذهله على ساحله او بالقرب من من شاطئهم
منذ نهايه الحرب البارده اكثر من اي مساحه
بحريه اخرى في العالم
حموله تجاريه ضخمه تمر عبر البحر الاسود
سجل طريق بحر الشمال الروسي الذي نال
الكثير من الاهتمام سجل رقما قياسيا في
الحموله بلغ نحو 35 مليون طن متري من
البضائع وذلك عام 2021
البحر الاسود هو المكان الذي تلتقي فيه
العديد من كبرى القوى في العالم روسيا
والاتحاد الاوروبي وتركيا وحلف شمال
الاطلسيه الذي يجلب معه الولايات المتحده
مع العلم انه لا تتمتع اي من هذه القوه
بالهيمنه على هاتف البحر
في الساعات الماضيه اعلنت موسكو ان القوات
الروسيه اجرت تدريبات عسكريه اطلقت خلالها
صواريخ في البحر الاسود
وقالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان سفن تابعه
لاصول البحر الاسود الروسي اطلقت صواريخ
كروز مضاده للسفن على زورق حدد هدفا في
منطقه التدريب القتالي في الجزء الشمالي
الغربي من البحر الاسود
وينضم الان الينا من جنيف الكساندرافير
الرئيس تحرير المجله العسكريه السويسريه
اهلا وسهلا بك السيد اذا هذه الرقعه
المائيه الصغيره
نريد ان نفهم اهميتها الاستراتيجيه سواء
للدول المطله عليه او للدوله المتصارعه
عليه
شخص لديه اهتمام في التاريخ يتذكر ان
الحرب الاساسيه في
التي تم او دخلت في قتال الدول بسبب
التجاره تجاره الاوكرانيه من
الحبوب والقمح من خلال هذا الممر المائي
ومدينه طرواده وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن
بحر صغير نسبيا كما تفضلتي ولكن القيمه
الاقتصاديه هي كبيره طيب ما الذي يعنيه ان
يسيطر عليه احد طرفين نزاع حاليا ما الذي
سيكون
تداعياته وتاثيره
يمكنني ان اعاير الموضوع بطريقه مختلفه
تماما اذا ما سمحت لان معظم النصوص
المرتبطه
بالقوى المشاطئه للبحر تتحدث عن السيطره
على الممرات
للسفن التجاريه
للشحنات اعتقد انه ما من طرف سوف يستثمر
بما يكفي من معدات واموال للسيطره الكامله
على البحر الاسود ولكننا نحن من جانب
الروس او من جانب الاوكرانيين
المنطق هو يقضي بالنسبه اليهم بمنع الطرف
الاخر من السيطره الكامله وفي الوقت نفسه
لا يود هو ان يسيطر بشكل كامل على هذا
البحر ولكن هذه المعارك الجاريه حاليا
والتي هي في تصاعد فعليا ما تاثيرها على
مسارات التجاره والملاحه البحريه
الانباء غير ساره لسوء الحظ لانه هذه
الحرب تؤثر بشكل كبير
على الممرات البحريه بفعل العمليات
البحريه وكما سبق واسلفت القوه من جهه
تمنع القوى الاخرى من السيطره على البحر
ما يعني ان الالغام زرعت في تلك البحار
وقوى النيتو حلف شمال الاطلسي يحاول ان
يدخل كاسحات الالغام لازاله الالغام خصوصا
بالنسبه الى المنطقه المحاذيه
للبحر او للشاطئ الروماني هناك اتفاق
بالحفاظ على ممر لمصلحه اوكرانيا
شكرا جزيلا لك اذا
سيد
من
جنيف كنت معنا اذا الكسن رئيس تحرير
المجله العسكريه السويسريه
[موسيقى]
لم يعد لدينا مكان في المدينه هي رساله
اريك ادمز عمده نيويورك للمهاجرين رساله
تزامنت مع اعلان السلطات نيويورك انها
ستوزع منشورات على الحدود الامريكيه مع
المكسيك لتشجيع طالبي اللجوء على الذهاب
الى مكان اخر يحدث هذا في نيويورك التي
كثيرا ما شكلت ملاذنا امنا للمهاجرين اما
في المنطقه الحدوديه الواقعه بين ليبيا
وتونس فثمت مشهد اخر يجسد حجم الماساه
صوره تم تداولها لجثه طالبه لجوء افريقيه
مع طفلها بعد ان لقيا حتفهما عطشا على
الحدود هكذا الحال اذا سلطات تشكو عدم
القدره على استيعاب مهاجرين بسبب زياده
الضغط على الخدمات واخرى تشكو وضعا
اقتصاديا ماذوما وفريق ثالث يكرر حججا
النيه وفي النهايه تتواصل ماساه طالبين
لجوء دون حل في الافق وال كل الامل ان
تنتهي محنت هؤلاء سواء في بلدانهم الاصليه
او في بلاد ياملون اللجوء اليها شكرا لكم
على حسن
[موسيقى]